bonsoir pour la merci d'être avec nous
en direct sur rt france on entend d'ici
1 le plus souvent parler de
manifestations contre israël quand on
est dans les territoires palestiniens
lassés contre un des leurs un dirigeant
palestinien c'est assez rare que les
palestiniens expriment leur colère
contre leur gouvernement
écoutez ce qui n'est pas si rare car ils
protestent ils l'ont fait contre le
président de l'autorité palestinienne
qui a été élu en 2005
cela s'est donc 16 ans qu'il est au
pouvoir de l'autorité palestinienne a t
il à 85 ans il est accusé de plusieurs
choses notamment de corruption et est
également accusé d'avoir eu des accords
avec israël concernant les questions de
sécurité alors que toute forme de
relations entre israël et l'autorité
palestinienne ont été dissoutes en 2014
oui ça a pu l'arrêter a encore décru
dans ce qu'il a annoncé qu'il n'y aurait
pas d'élections cette année il a annulé
ces élections sa population sa
popularité donc en décroissance
l'autorité palestinienne dont le
président est mahmoud abbas est dirigée
par le parti fatah et ce parti accuse le
hamas parti du mal d'avoir orchestré ces
manifestations inhabituelles
il est inhabituel d'avoir des
manifestations dans la bande de gaza
contre le hamas mais c'est non plus
fréquentes avoir des manifestations en
cisjordanie contre l'autorité
palestinienne contre le parti dirigeant
le fatah cependant nous n'avons pas eu
de telles manifestations tant de
frustration et de colère tant d'appels
pour à la démission de mahmoud abbas est
que nous voyons en ce moment alors lors
de la signature des accords d'oslo
c'était en 1993 on se souvient que
mahmoud abbas avait déclaré les accords
d'oslo nous conduiront à un état ou un
désastre on peut dire que c'est plutôt
un désastre au vu des palestiniens après
quinze ans au pouvoir il n'a pas pu
empêcher l'expansion israélienne cela il
peine à qui l'on demande
la plupart des personnes qui ont
effectivement que c'est un désastre qui
a eu aucun progrès entre israël et la
palestine
mais qui est responsable de cela
est ce vraiment à mahmoud abbas
plusieurs personnes auront des avis
divergents
les israéliens ressens de la frustration
envers mahmoud abbas il considère qu'il
n'a pas respecté sa parole il y a
actuellement une rupture totale entre le
hamas et la bande de gaza et le fatah et
le reste la cisjordanie
d'un autre côté le président mahmoud
abbas pourrait accuser israël de la même
chose pourrait dire que les israéliens
ne sont pas fiables et que toutes les
promesses de benyamin nétanyahou ont
disparu sans être respectée donc la
plupart des gens sont d'accord pour dire
qu'il n'y a pas eu de progrès en tout
cas pas de progrès depuis 2014 lors de
l'interruption de la dernière tournée de
négociations le blâme tombe sur les
palestiniens et mahmoud abbas sur israël
en fonction de la personne à laquelle on
demande notamment on peut blâmer
benyamin netanyhou l'ex chef du
gouvernement israélien
clairement pour life que le hamas est
aujourd'hui plus populaire aux yeux des
de la grande majorité des palestiniens
que les le fatah on sait pas le cas
ce serait intéressant d'organiser des
élections palestiniennes
car on pourrait voir si le hamas elle
remporte contre sept factions rivales du
fatah l'une des raisons de l'annulation
des élections le mois dernier et
peut-être que l'armée la basse redouter
une victoire du hamas
on pense sur le terrain que si des
élections étaient tenus le hamas
remporterait les élections dans la bande
de gaza et dans d'autres régions où le
fatah était de pouvoir la plupart des
palestiniens dans la bande de gaza
ressemble et la frustration envers
mahmoud abbas ce trait son départ en
cisjordanie il y a encore plusieurs
années
les gens n'étaient pas aussi prêts à
admettre leur soutien du hamas et était
difficile de trouver des soutiens du
hamas prêt à témoigner devant une caméra
mais aujourd'hui lorsqu'on se rend en
cisjordanie le soutien pour le hamas est
bien plus explicite
l'autre raison de l'augmentation de la
violence c'est que le 24 juin un
opposant de mahmoud abbas nommé donc
nommé nizar baraka a été tué alors qu'il
avait été arrêté par la police
il est donc noir en détention et ils
n'ont pas donné de raison pour ce décès
on dit qu'ils ont ouvert une enquête
mais on les accuse de meurtre de cet
homme
et c'est donc cette dernière étincelle
qui a provoqué les manifestations en
cisjordanie
[Musique]
certaines personnes accusent également
les policiers de l'autorité
palestinienne de se dresser de
s'habiller en civil et de battre des
manifestants et les personnes qui
marchent contre l'autorité palestinienne
donc on observe ce genre de troubles
temps en
sigean thani depuis plusieurs jours cet
opposant d'ailleurs qui dérangeait
également israël
clairement la présence au pouvoir de
mahmoud abbas arrange les israéliens ce
sera ma dernière question si l'on me
demandait tout même s'il serait bien
inspirée non ce n'est pas une bonne
chose
les israéliens disent qu'ils n'ont pas
de partenaire du côté palestinien 2014
en 2005 lors de l'élection de mahmoud
abbas la situation d israël et les
israéliens étaient beaucoup plus
optimiste mais depuis les négociations
se sont interrompues et il n'y a plus eu
de progrès pour les israéliens mahmoud
abbas n'est pas un partenaire faire la
paix mais si des élections devaient se
tenir dans les territoires occupés et
que le hamas remporté ces élections il
faut savoir qu israël ne reconnaît pas
hamas le considère comme un mouvement
terroriste et ramasse ne reconnaît pas
israël et appellent à sa destruction
donc il n'y aurait aucune interaction
possible donc une interaction formel
entre israël et le hamas si le hamas a
rêvé de pouvoir afin de répondre à votre
question
si quelqu'un devait si quelqu'un du
hamas devait remplacer mahmoud abbas il
y aurait encore moins de progrès mais il
existe d'autres candidats qui pourraient
remplacer mahmoud abbas qui viennent de
ce même parti du fatah donc si un
candidat plus populaire en palestine
plus jeunes et qui n'était pas accusé de
corruption remplacer mahmoud abbas
alors les négociations entre la
palestine et israël pourrait redémarrer
mais tout cela dépend de qui elle
remplacera mahmoud abbas qui est qui
sera le dirigeant du côté palestinien
merci beaucoup place tailleur d'avoir
été avec nous en direct sur arte france
pourvu de l'est
derrière ce soir